this video is an introduction to pepper
panic saga crates and how they work how
to remove them how to work around them
destroy them as you can see here this is
the first crates level level 2060 as you
can see there are two types of crepes
crates there's stage 1 which are just
wooden boxes with the like a stamp of a
pepper on them and then stage two which
has the metal pepper with some chains
and some extra reinforcements the stage
one take one hit or match right next to
them to remove them in states tues take
two so the easiest way to remove crates
is to make a match that will touch the
touch them and as the match is made it
will remove it so you can see in the
beginning this level set up so that we
can remove some crates right away by
making these two three pepper matches
and that will remove all the pup all the
crates that are touching the peppers
which will be these three here these two
underneath and these three on this side
the crates all hold a pepper inside
someone never moved you'll see what's
you know what's behind it and in some of
the levels the colors that are inside
are fixed so you know if you're looking
for a particular color or you know what
colors inside then you can use that to
your advantage you know to remove them
as you need to so we'll make this match
whereas you see those crates disappear
and then we'll just work our way down
making matches that touch them and
remove them as we go
and you know that's it's pretty
straightforward how that works one thing
to keep in mind about them is that
explosions don't actually damage them
matches do and shockwaves do but an
actual explosion won't do anything to
them here's an example this is you know
for pepper match it'll make a shockwave
and go down and it'll hit this first
crate on the top and remove it so you
can see we clear it out that way we'll
make another for pepper match here that
will send the shockwave down and knock
the chains off of this this and make it
a stage one it'll also cause this one to
explore and you'll see that that doesn't
doesn't hurt those crates that are
sitting nearby so that's that's the
basics of how they work we'll look at
one other level and look at when it gets
a little bit more complicated
this is level 2 17 this is where they
get a little bit more interesting they
function as an obstruction all the time
and you know you can't obviously we
can't do anything on this side until we
remove some so to start out we'll have
to clear this row out first and then
we'll have to send shockwaves across to
the other side of the board to make it
so that we can match these green peppers
all right so we'll make a match that
will knock the chains off there and set
up these other two matches where we can
you know make some remove some more of
them as we go once we get them cleared
out for the most part we'll look for
opportunity to send shockwaves over here
so that we can make progress on our
goals so this is a l-shaped match it'll
start that process along
and in you know most levels like this
one you know the getting rid of the
crates first is the most important thing
and we don't really need to worry about
much else these peppers have timers and
we won't be able to do much with them if
they if we can't get over there before
they count down again as you can see the
explosions don't do anything to let us
create
so now we just need one more shock wave
in this area to be able to make a match
over there and open up the board there a
pretty simple feature but it actually
like them the way that they especially
when they're using this way they make
the levels more interesting
when I first played this level oh I
didn't think it seemed really really
complicated but when you take a little
bit of time and think about it you can
see that just take some more coordinated
approach i guess you'd say
so now we remove the one that was in the
middle we can make a three pepper match
and that's going to take out all the
ones that are in the surrounding area
and even though some of these are going
to turn you can see that we now made
progress and you can clear out the
crates that's really all there is to
them it's they are an obstruction like I
said and in there are levels where
knowing what colors are inside will help
like on this one purple peppers don't
drop onto the board at all until you
open up these crates on the outside and
that's one of our level requirements so
you know we need to do that what you'll
notice that once once you start to match
your greens and your Purple's they'll
start to fall on this side and so that
they really so the level actually
changes from the number of colors that
are in play as you go so it's pretty
interesting and pretty neat if you got
any questions about how crates work
leave a comment and we'll respond as
soon as we can make sure you like the
video if you found it helpful subscribe
to our channel and check out our full
guide on crates at pepper panic tips com
thanks